cbs and 60 minutes coming under major
fire
it's over a story they did on florida
governor ron desantis
the program claimed that desantis gave
preferential treatment to grocery store
chain
publix in the vaccine rollout because
they donated to his campaign
but the florida governor is hitting back
hard against the accusation
he's accusing 60 minutes of deceptively
editing the piece
here's what the clip looked like when it
aired on cbs
publix as you know donated a hundred
thousand dollars to your campaign
and then you rewarded them with the
exclusive rights to distribute the
vaccination in palm beach
what you're saying is right how is that
not paid that's a fake narrative
i met with the county mayor i met with
the administrator i met with all the
folks at palm beach county and i said
here's some of the options we can do
more drive-through sites we can give
more to hospitals
we can do the publix and they said we
think that would be the easiest thing
for our residents
but melissa mckinlay the county
commissioner in the glades told us
the governor never met with her about
the public's deal
the criticism is that it's pay to play
governor it's wrong it's a fake
narrative
i just disabused you of the narrative
and you don't care about the facts
because obviously i laid it out for you
in a way
that is irrefutable and here's what cbs
cut out including why desantis decided
to choose publix
as we got into january we wanted to
expand the distribution points
so yes you had the counties you had some
drive-through sites you had hospitals
that were doing a lot
but we wanted to get it into communities
more so we reached out to other
retail pharmacies publix walmart
obviously cbs and walgreens had to
finish that mission
and we said we're going to we're going
to use you as soon as you're done with
that for the publix
they were the first one to raise their
hand say they were ready to go and you
know what we did it on a trial basis
i had three counties i actually showed
up that weekend
and talked to seniors across four
different publics how was the experience
is this good
should you think this is the way to go
and it was a hundred percent positive
cbs continues to stand behind their
story
saying today our story sunday night
speaks for itself
dana perino let me begin with you
desantis claims he's being smeared
by left-wing corporate new york media he
points out that cbs has not done a story
on
embattled new york governor andrew cuomo
but the cbs people say is that santa's
turned down two interviews
so i'm thinking is this a normal press
versus politician
conflict that's being blown up by the
grievance media by political
polarization
sometimes i would agree with you on that
one in this case no when the cbs says
that the story speaks for itself
yep it sure does and it's been going now
for two days if they wanted to help ron
desantis
solidify his position as one of the top
republican leaders in america they could
not have done a better job
the way that cbs edited that video that
would have been pulled off the air if it
was a if it's a political ad
and the opponent complained it would
have been pulled off for less um
you know i have a little history of
dealing with cbs on such deception
um i don't think that it is um too far
to say that this is reminiscent of
things from the past where they forged
documents and then aired them
they defended it for several days when
it came to george w bush's national
guard service and then all of a sudden
oh wait actually reverse course and move
on
the opportunity for governor desantis
right now i think is
to move beyond just talking to the
republican base
he has a great story to tell about
florida and how florida has done
in covet we have dan bongino here who
can talk about this with more
direct experience but you have
florida and texas who had a different
approach for dealing
with the covet and the lockdowns and try
to figure out a way to keep the economy
open while keeping people safe
meantime you have these democratic stars
of governor newsom and
cuomo with the worst records and so
this is an opportunity for desantis to
move beyond just talking about cbs
deceptively editing
that piece about him the last thing i
would point out is i interviewed the
mayor of palm beach this morning he's a
democrat he
raised his hand immediately after seeing
that 60 minutes
interview and said this is not right
this is not what happened this is wrong
and he said that he you know he talked
to them for over 50 minutes but that
nothing that he said was included in the
piece today when cbs issued another
statement about this they said
well we talked to that mayor like well
he would talk to him but nothing sunk in
and he feels that it was deceptive so if
you have a democratic mayor defending
the republican governor who is at the
top of his
political field then you know you have a
problem at cbs
well here's the here's the video
i participated in speaking with a
producer of 60 minutes for probably over
45 minutes and gave very direct facts
about
the governor's meeting that i had with
him here in my office
a few months ago and when i watched the
piece i was just taken
taken aback really that none of my
comments um
none of my perspective was included
katie you got two florida democrats
including that governor that you just
saw
saying that you know they agree with the
governor that
in fact they thought public should be
used to vaccinate people in the state
um but at the same time 60 minutes
factually noted that publix
you know the heiress to the public's
fortune gave major donation
to publix to desantis i should say
to his political action committee just
before
that big contract was given to public so
i just want to know if you think
isn't that a story
no first of all one hundred thousand
dollars in florida
as a campaign donation is really not a
lot of money
publix is the most popular grocery store
chain and they explain that
there's a publix within a mile and a
half of most senior
communities in florida which is why they
decided to go with them first and why
they decided to vaccinate
seniors first but if you want to talk
about the amount of money if that's the
scandal here for pay to play which is
obviously what cbs is trying to go for
gavin newsom received 23 million dollars
from blue shield
in california and then gave the
exclusive rights to vaccination
to blue shield in california so 23
million dollars
versus one hundred thousand dollars of
routine
political donation to ron desantis
there's no story there and yet cbs
continues to say that
you know they did the right thing they
reached out to the right people
but what i like about the story is that
you look at florida and it's obvious
that democrats and republicans
unlike the rest of the country were able
to rise above
above politics and partisanship to get
the job done when it came to getting
people vaccinated quickly and so i think
that's really what the focus is here and
we'll see what cbs does
okay so greg you have politicians though
in minority areas in florida pointing
out that they were not getting access
to the vaccine in comparable way to
people who were
wealthy and donors to desantis is that
fair to point out as a criticism
i don't know because it's uh it's simply
one variable right and
and when you're doing something like
this there are a number of variables
going on in terms of
age and risk factors the thing that
gets me there are two funny things about
this there's actually something
hilarious about this when 60 minutes
in their defense of this bragged that
this report
stirred debate and prompted a strong
reaction
but they neglect to say that they
stirred debate
through its corrupt methods it wasn't
because it wasn't because it was the
facts
uh created this this this debate so it's
like saying like my
incompetence raises awareness of
incompetent people
the strong reaction is over the
dishonest manipulation of tape in the
second part of this
and this maybe is the best part cbs
claims that they edited the piece for
clarity
that's like saying uh we're lying for
the truth
because you could consider this logic
that that context
gets in the way of a story and what
sadly they kind of are
right the media's grim intention all
along is to shape their narrative
and in order to do that you have to
remove the context whether it's
washington post and the covington kids
or
katie couric remember katie couric with
those gun owners or 60 minutes
they look at people's lives like a block
of clay
and it's up to them to carve the story
of discord
out of it to make money because a
positive uplifting story of which there
are many involving desantis
that's not going to get them clicks so
they have to find the negative
the the negative element in every story
in this case it was linking publics to
this
but this is um this is always the the
media's goal
positive stories don't pay the goal is
to manage
destruction of your target it's the
richard jewell effect
so dan you know a lot about florida as
dana was saying
and you know it seems like uh desantis's
fortunes politically are rising
conservatives defending him he's a hero
although what you get is a lot of people
say you know this is the same guy who
believed
trump's claims of election fraud what do
you see
wow that was interesting how you threw
that one in there juan that has
absolutely nothing to do with the story
but
really nice try um so this is a total
lie
this is a story designed to appeal to
idiots
so if you're a [ __ ] this story on 60
minutes absolutely appeals to you you
think there's something there
it's totally made up there's not a shred
of truth to it
now if you actually live in florida like
i do you can't swing a wiffle ball bat
without hitting a publix
because there's one in every direction
so let's just think this
by the way also juan publix donates to
everyone in florida because they have
816 stores in florida
so you know just like everyone else they
donate to politicians but let me just
bring this up
if you were going to distribute the
vaccine would you do it in a place that
had 800 look this is a tough one for
liberals so think this through folks
libs take you know take the blinders off
and think this through
do you want to put it in a location that
has 800 locations
or 300. now i know the liberals are
because they've been vaccinated to the
truth right
i know that's hard for them to figure
out one but 816 locations
publix is probably a good place to start
with vaccinations
i'm just going to throw that out there